So let me show you an example. Let's let's switch to markdown talk
about.
Let's see a system of equation as in.
In practice and we're matrices come
into the picture.
Okay, you want to look here on the right?
Okay, I'm gonna type markdown markdown code.
But you look at it right by the way, if you want to learn about
markdown a latex, which I'm going to be using you can also go to
the dashboard. There's a there's some reading material which you can
check out.
linear program example
So let's say this is our objective function.
Okay, we want to either maximize
or minimize this so we want to modify
the parameters or find out what X and
Y must be equal to so that this function will give us the maximum
value or the minimum value. It depends on the problem. If you try
to reduce costs that you would want to minimize the function.
If you want to for example increase Revenue then obviously it
want to maximize a function.
Oh one notation that you might see is for example.
The cute this word Max that's used before.
the functions name
so you may have seen this.
So this this says maximize the value and then there's
something called ARG Max.
Which means the arguments that maximize the
function?
Okay.
So we want to maximize this function.
And these are the constraints that we have.
Okay.
We have this inequality.
We have these two inequalities in both X and Y Must Be.
Greater than or equal to greater than equal to
0. Yes.
Now the way we solve this.
The way we can the way we deal with.
These inequalities as we must solve them.
And what we're about to do is very similar to what we will do with systems of
linear equations and linear programming where we get to something called the reduced
Echelon form. I'll show you a picture of it in a moment.
so what we do first is we represent the inequalities
not as inequalities, but
as equations like so
so
these are the constraints.
as
equations
So these are inequalities.
These are equations. Okay. All we've
done is we've substituted the inequality with equal sign.
That's let's label this equation. You want an equation two. Now
what we want to do again is find the roots of
both of these equations
So we want to know what x is equal to Y is equal and what
Y is equal to once we find what x and y equal to then we will
find a point that we could put place in the quadrant
and one of the and irrelevant quadrant.
And by doing that we will have found a feasible region.
So what we will do.
Is we will subtract?
the second equation from the first
so we will subtract.
2X
from X Y from Y and 4,000 and
one 3000 so we will subtract these together.
Okay.
And what does that give us?
It gives us x equals to 1,000. Why because well if
you subtract y from y y is eliminated 2x minus
X, that's just X and 4,000 minus 3,000. That's
just 1000 again. This
is classical laundry, right if you remember this is why I said they're pretty
regular for linear algebra is classical algebra.
This is just you know,
Adding on both sides subtracting your both sides
moving terms the other side of the equation.
Okay, so if you know these then
the linear programming and linear algebra are within your
grasp.
Okay. So now we have found the first.
Root, we found the first variable X must
be equal to 1000. Well, now we can do is we can
plug in X into one of these inequalities. So what we will
do is we will plug in X into equation to
okay, so we will put 1,000 here
for x and then we will solve for y.
And we do that.
We will get the following.
Right. All you can see we've done is
We have plugged in 1004. Excuse me. We've applied we'll plug
the 1,000 for x.
Actually, yeah for here.
So here we have X Plus y equals 3,000 now we have 1,000 plus
y equals 3,000.
And then we just solve for y which gives us.
now what we have done is we found.
Y as well, so we have the points.
X and Y
and what are these points equal to?
X is 1000
and Y is 2,000.
Okay.
Now if I want to show you a picture of this.
feasible region
There we go there the the other points. So that
is our first constraint that is our second constraint. We
use we perform arithmetic operation
on both of them. We see in this case. All we did was subtract now
practice.
You're gonna you're gonna have more than two constraints and
you're going to do a lot more.
row operations
something in linearity. I'll cut this in moment. But as
you can see once we have found the point once we have found the roots,
we now have or are able to plot the feasible
region.
So as long as the parameters.
Are within this feasible region then our objective function is optimized.
And I can optimization means that the function will give us maximum.
Results or minimum results depending on what we're trying
to do.
This is essentially what linear programming is.
Okay. Now obviously this is a very simple example, there's more something that
we also cover in this code is called a Simplex algorithm.
And if you learn
linear programming, then you can even attach something called
nonlinear programming where you're constraints are
not linear, so they are polynomials.
Okay.
There's a that was a simple example now.
Let's see how this relates to linear algebra. Let me open another tab here.
This is an example in linear algebra.
so if we take
a sequence of equations that are set of equations like so
again, you want to look here right in this panel.
Let me activate it.
here again we have
A set of linear equations I can how
do we know it's linear all of the variables or I should
say. None of the variables are
to the power of two or above everything is the power of one.
That's why it's called linear produces a line. There was a square
or
If it was square or cubed, then
we would we would looking at curves.
What we do a linear algebra is we take all of
these terms both from the left and right side of the
equation.
And we isolate the constants like so.
So we take two.
And one and one from XYZ respectively,
so that's what we get here.
and then of course the fourth column
is a
the value of the rights of the equation
The way we would solve this what we do is we have
the essentially find the roots. We have to find out what x is equal to what Y is
equal to what Z is equal to.
By eliminating these constants like
we did in the linear program example.